did you polish your like you are your
favorite burgundy with those earrings
you look stunning
thank you beautiful did you watch mr.
Rajah growing up haha why are you so do
we scare you I know but you grew up here
so I grew up in Brooklyn oh yeah I loved
it and you watched it as a kid yeah my
brother and I we watched it all the time
I mean I junk around but I was like it
was I preparing for this since I'm 5
years old like I remember just all of it
and it's all attached like a really
sweet time in life well you didn't know
much about anything yet and he was sort
of your entryway into so much of like
what it is to think about your feelings
or what it is like yeah explore life and
this really calm sort of patiently yeah
so who do you play what's your role in
the movie tell everyone I play Andrea
I'm his his ball and chain and on our
relationship is this it's in a
complicated place you know I think with
relationships you know there's sometimes
these points where there's just
miscommunication and and we're just
missing each other like we're both on
two different pages at the moment and
we're trying to get especially me
realizing exactly and so now we have a
newborn and we're trying to get
realigned and it's not quite happening I
loved y'all like on screen together it
was so well done like all the hurt the
laughing elevate it was just like so
well played out to how actual
relationships how we interact with each
other it was really good but you you
actually have a really good like
neighbors story like growing up right
like when you had your landlady I heard
yeah you know what my land bless her
heart and bless people who are like this
I was so broke and just trying to be an
artist and trying to stay true to my art
and my landlady in Brooklyn
frederica she'll love this she's an
artist and she basically let me stay in
my apartment because I was an artist and
and I called her one day I said look I
really can't afford to be here you know
and I don't want to hold you up and I
don't want to feel like I owe you so
I'll leave and I just want to give you
some notice she said look
just stay I know what you're trying to
do I know where you're trying to go in
life forget any late fees forget like
any paying on time just when you can get
it to me get it you're a good tenant I'd
rather just see you try and succeed and
you can stay in the place where prices
are skyrocketing and you can get anyone
to come in and play double what I'm
paying and she just really invested in
me and that kind of thing you know gets
ya passed on in some way I heard about
that story and then yeah I was just like
what a beautiful way and then you to
take that and pay it forward you know
one day absolutely beautiful
neighborhood kind of vibe very much so
did you get I'm asking did you get the
same gift from Tom Hanks at the end okay
listen I was so happy you didn't know
what about funny season like a writing
like something to ride a horse or loose
shift paper this is tobacco I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this